-That's got to feel good, bud.
Welcome back to the show.
I always love seeing you here.
Thanks for coming back.
-I love being here.
It's great to be back.
-I got -- When I said hi to you,
I got mustache envy.
Immediately, I go,
"That is a real stache."
Look at that thing.
-It is real.
-Yeah. I was going to say.
Yeah. Wow.
I mean, is it --
-New 'tache new job, you know?
-Oh, yeah.
So, this is for a movie, yeah.
-It's for a movie.
-Oh.
-Playing a cop in the '80s
in a film called "The Order,"
which I start
in a couple of weeks.
-Do you like that better
than a fake mustache?
-Yeah, for sure.
I wore a fake, like,
beard or mustache maybe once.
It was, like -- You know,
it's like acting through a rug,
and you can't smile,
particularly.
So, yeah, I like growing the --
-"Police. Don't move.
Freeze! Freeze!"
-And the smiles,
because you get the "ping!"
-Ping! It pops up.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I recently -- Because
I just want to show you
how hard it is
for me to grow a mustache.
This is my
senior yearbook photo.
And it's -- Can you see it?
Can you zoom in?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a real --
That's that age where
that takes months.
-That was commitment.
-You're like...[ Grunts ]
-Yeah. And if the wind blows,
it just kind of
blows in the wind.
It was a very wispy,
free mustache.
I wanted to
-I unscrew this every night.
-No, that's a fantastic one.
That is a solid.
I want to ask you about this,
because the Internet's
all abuzz.
You just wrapped
"Star Wars: Skeleton Crew."
And there's a lot of buzz
going around it
and not a ton of information
about what it's about.
And this is all I know so far.
"Jude Law is in
'Star Wars: Skeleton Crew,'
an unnamed Jedi assisting
four children on an adventure."
That's vague.
-That's one perspective.
-Wow. I'm intrigued.
-That sounds good.
-You're not really allowed
to talk much?
-Not much.
There are wonderful,
as you can imagine,
twists and turns
and reveals and --
-Are there four children?
-There are four children.
-Okay.
-They are between
the ages of 10 and 12.
They get lost.
They come from
a kind of mysterious planet.
They get blasted off and lost
in the world of "Star Wars."
And Jon Watts,
the brilliant director
of the last
"Spider-Man" trilogy,
he headed up the directors
and he --
Yeah, it's got a little more --
Well, they described it
as is a little more
Amblin, meaning,
you know, it's
an adventure of kids,
but it's not in the kids world.
The jeopardy is real.
-Yeah.
-And it was a blast,
I'll tell you.
-What's it like being on those
giant sets of "Star Wars"?
-The thing I underestimated
was the experience
of acting opposite droids
and creatures,
which, of course, are all there.
And so you get to work
with, at times, you know,
five, six, seven puppeteers.
And these people are masters.
So, you know,
your conversations are like,
"Oh, who does the left arm?
Okay, you do the left arm.
So, do you want to put
the left arm, like, here
or when you look at me --"
And it's a really weird,
different type of acting,
but it's fun.
And then, of course,
you got to pinch yourself
because you're sat
there surrounded
by this weird creature
and this --
-Yeah, yeah.
You're like, "Am I --"
-And then this robot.
And you're doing a really
serious scene, like, talking.
-It's almost like fantasy camp.
-Totally.
-Right? You're like, "I can't
believe I get to do this."
-I got --
I've been very lucky.
I've worked with some
particularly respectable actors.
But I've never been star-struck
like I was when I met a Jawa.
-Yeah.
-I'm not joking.
-Yes!
-I saw a Jawa walking by.
I was like,
"Oh, I can't believe.
It's real Jawa."
-"It's a real Jawa."
Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
-Is Jon Favreau
involved with this one?
-Yes, he is.
-Oh, he is.
-Yeah.
-He's fantastic, man.
-He is.
-I like that guy.
-And he's got a wonderful
family feel
in Manhattan Beach,
where we shot it.
There were a couple
of other projects going on.
Yeah, it was a
really wonderful experience.
I hope you will have
the same experience watching it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're excited. It'll be good.
-Thank you.
-I want to talk about
"Peter Pan & Wendy."
-Yeah.
-You were almost
unrecognizable as Captain Hook.
There you are. Yeah.
-The dastardly.
-Yeah.
-Dastardly.
-Dastardly is right. Yeah.
That's a fun call
to get, though, huh?
Again, speaking of,
like, kind of dreams,
I mean, "Star Wars," obviously,
but also "Peter Pan" and Disney.
-Yeah. It was a little daunting.
-Yeah.
-Filling some big boots.
-Yeah, some great actors
have played --
-Really great actors.
But this -- There was
a great take in this script
where you understand
a little more about
why Hook is the way he is,
how he came to Neverland,
the relationship between him and
Peter and how it really started.
And so you really get into,
I suppose,
understanding a little bit of
the damage that was done to him
and why he's quite
as awful as he is.
And we went back to the book
for some detail and insight.
But, obviously, you know,
I leaned pretty heavily
comfortably on the shoulders
of the great actors
who have played him before
and I hope brought a little bit
of my own insight, yeah.
-I feel like it
must be, like, so much fun
to walk on a giant pirate ship
as Captain Hook.
You'd be like, "That's right.
Yeah, respect."
-It's up there.
-"Respect."
-It's up there with,
yeah, as far as --
You realize, I suppose,
suddenly, how easy it is
for a group of men
dressed as pirates
to fall into the opportunity
of living that for real.
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, you jump right in.
-Once we were all on --
First of all,
this ship was extraordinary.
And they would remove the stairs
so no one could get off,
because we were on a gimbal
so the thing could move like
you were at sea.
And you on there --
We were on there for hours
with our bad teeth
and the shaved heads
and everyone -- We "arrgh!"
A lot of that going on.
-Yeah.
-Sea chanties.
-And they all
fell into calling me Captain,
which I didn't mind, of course.
I was like,
"You salute me all day long."
-Were the kids scared?
Were they intimidated?
-So, we tried -- David Lowery,
our wonderful director,
had the idea of really trying
to encourage them
not to see me
when I wasn't Hook.
So I just stayed as Hook
the whole time,
which was an opportunity just
to be really scary and mean.
Sounds kind of awful.
But, you know, you didn't
want -- I didn't want
suddenly to be talking to
a little 6-year-old dude,
and then suddenly,
it's like, "Right.
You hate me.
I'm Hook. I'm Hook."
So, instead,
I just stuck as Hook.
-Yeah.
-And, yeah, a lot of the
reactions you see in the film
are their reactions to me
for the first time
or as the man himself, you know?
-Did they ever get to meet Jude?
-They met Jude at the end.
And I did what every adult
should do to bribe children.
I hired an ice-cream van
and I drove it on-site
and gave out ice cream.
-Come on. That's a good man.
That's exactly right.
-Nothing like chocolate ice
cream to persuade a child,
and you're alright.
-"I'm not that bad, really.
Yeah, I was just playing a
character, yeah."
And then the hook
is on the right hand, right?
-Yeah. I had to learn to
fight -- sword-fight
with my left hand.
-Wow. That's a cool skill.
-Well, first of all,
I had to learn to sword-fight,
and then it was like, "And now I
have to learn to sword-fight."
You know what was surprising
was how un...
What's the word?
I mean, just how unskilled the
left hand, my left hand, was.
I had to do all these little
routines every day for an hour
before I was allowed
to do anything, with a weight,
where I had to just sort of
learn to use my --
I was like -- I had this
awful left hand, yeah.
-I heard that,
like, if you try --
If you're right-handed,
try brushing your teeth
with your left hand,
and it's, like,
apparently mind-blowing.
-Once I had the hook on,
it was hard to take it off,
because it was under
all these layers
and it was strapped on
and what have you.
So I milked that all day long,
because I can fight
with my left hand, but,
"Oh, can you pass me the..."
-Smart man.
-"Pass me the cup of tea."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Gaffigan, Gaffigan, Gaffigan,
pass me --"
Jim Gaffigan is in the movie.
He plays Smee.
-He plays Smee.
-How's Jim Gaffigan?
-Well, we would sit around --
I mean, he should be in
stand-up, that guy.
He's so funny.
-Yeah, he should
give it a shot.
-He's really entertaining.
-He should give it a try.
-We'd be sat there talking for
hours about everything,
and he was --
He's so smart and so humorous.
And then we'd both kind of laugh
because we're dressed
as pirates.
-Yeah. And you're talking
a serious conversation.
-Sat on a boat.
And then I'd be like, "Shouldn't
we be doing something?
We've been at this for an hour."
-He's the best.
-And it's like,
"Do you need us at all?"
They're like,
"No, no, you're fine.
You're just in the background."
I'm like, "Great.
Jim, tell me,
what do you think about the..."
-Yeah, tell me another routine.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jude Law in
"Peter Pan & Wendy."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-[ Groans ]
Sorry, Captain.
-Mr. Smee!
Smee...
make a note
my cabin needs a new door.
-A new door, yes.
Uh, right.
M-Might I say, captain, uh,
that will be your third door
this month.
-And it won't be the last.
Where's my telescope?
Telescope? Smee.
-Telescope at hand, Captain.
-Speak not to me of hands, Smee.
-Huh. I see your point. Uh...
-That's what I'm
talking about there.
Jude Law, everybody.
"Peter Pan & Wendy" is streaming
exclusively on Disney+
this Friday.
Joshua Jackson
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.